That is the textual point of
view, some unique aspect.
>> How is working with
Spielberg different from other
directions?
>> I work for as many other
directors.
Many wonderful directors.
Stephen and I have been
together for a very long time.
It's different in the sense
that we know each other so
well.
We have a shorthand of working
together after all these many
years.
He's a close friend, he is many
things.
He's a producer and a studio
and a writer.
And a friend.
He's also not something.
He's not something you can say
no to.
His family and I love him
dearly.
And I think he's an
inspiration.
Can I museum a?
I don't know.
He's amuse.
He's an inspiration.
>> Speaking of inspirations,
you have won five oscars.
Your nomination for the fable
mans is your 53rd, it put she
behind only one man, well
Disney who had 59 nominations
for oscars.
What does the recognition from
the oscars mean to you?
>> Well, it seems very unreal
to me, Chris.
How could you get 53
nominations?
It's impossible.
No one's live that long to be
able to --
you couldn't plan that.
I never set out to say I have
all these nominations.
It boggles my mind.
I have to credit music and what
it does for our lives and for
sustaining our spirit and
enriching our souls.
It's like great poetry and
literature.
It's something to live for and
to live by.
>> One of the things I love to
do is to dig into the process.
How artists like you create.
What was your thought about
jaws?
What was it you're trying to do
with a theme from jaws?
>> In the case of jaws I
wondered what to do.
How to identify the shock.
I thought something unstoppable
like the attack of a shark,
there is no way you can defend
yourself from that.
Something is approaching
inevitably and it's dangerous.
And even repetitive and low and
ominous.
And start quietly and speed up.
>> Let's see what you came up
with here.
>> All right, good.
And that is why I didn't go
into the water for several
years.
Spielberg says that score was
responsible for at least half
of success.
>> It might be interesting.
That clip that you have shown,
how it started slowly in softly
and how it accelerates as it
gets closer to this warmer.
It becomes a greater danger.
It gets louder and louder.
A very simple and unstoppable
rhythmic structure.
It's relentless and unstoppable
and maybe something you want to
get away from.
>> Definitely something you
want to get away from.
Let's go on to the theme from
star wars.
Here it is.
>>
I've got to say, I saw the
movie when it came out.
I never heard anything like
that.
What was your thought?
Of what you want to achieve.
How do you go about it both in
terms of the music and how you
orchestrated?
>> I worked backwards, Chris.
This piece is the last piece I
wrote in the process of writing
an hour and a half music salon.
I couldn't seem to get a
heraldic theme that was --
that had the heroic aspect that
the orchestra can present in a
short period of time.
Two hours to play a symphony.
I finally in desperation really
really worked out this thing
with jumps of faith.
Jumping up to dough again.
I could show you that it seemed
to be a direct strong and
heroic and clear sonorous sound
from the orchestra.
And I smile and I hear it.
Just as an inside thing.
And it's a particularly
electrifying brass
interpretation.
I don't know how much credit I
can take that.
The grace brass section of the
symphony excited over not me
conducting it but the arrival
of the new principal in this
heraldic phrase.
>> Then there is the score from
E.T..
You say it's one of your
favorite films.
Here is the climactic scene.
Spielberg said without John
Williams bikes can't fly.
>> Well, I love that scene.
And it always interests me
wanting to know at least how
fast you have to go on a
bicycle to escape philosophy.
To escape gravity.
What escapes velocity?
I asked the gentleman from nasa,
he said 17,500 miles an hour.
If we can go 17,500 miles an,
hour the bike will take off and
we will fly over the moon.
We buy this, the police were
chasing the kids on the
bicycles.
They reach the speeds and
flyaway.
It's wonderful the way we
accept that.
It's something about film that
the magic of what can be done
with cameras and imagination
and special effects.
And yes orchestras are playing
scenes that have lifted.
>> Let's talk about the
difference that music makes to
a movie.
Here is the classic theme from
raiders of the lost ark.
>> Spielberg says that the
two
of you had a performance and an
appearance in a concert where
you played a scene from one of
the raiders movies without any
music and that frankly he says
it was wrong and boring.
And then you played it with the
music, you played it with the
orchestra.
It was a totally different
experience.
>> It is completely different.
It will contract and compress
the time certainly.
It's quick music.
It seemed like the one you
refer to is about four minutes.
Running at without the music,
it seems like six minutes.
It's almost like riding a
horse.
You don't feel it.
If you're fighting the